[Música]
[Aplausos]
Irlanda es uno de los países más ricos
del mundo pero eso ya lo sabéis
prácticamente todas las grandes
tecnológicas desde Apple hasta Google
tienen su sede europea en Irlanda Es más
si trabajas en algo relacionado con Ite
seguro que alguna vez te habrá llegado
alguna oferta para trabajar en dublín o
en cork lo que probablemente no sepáis
es que es realmente rico quiero decir es
más rico incluso que Suiza pero no solo
eso Irlanda Lleva más de una década
creciendo a ritmos de país emergente os
acordáis del año 2020 Sí ese año el del
coronavirus ese año en el que
prácticamente todos los países del Mundo
entraron en recesión Pues bien Irlanda
no solo siguió creciendo sino que su pib
creció al 5,8% para que os hagáis una
idea estas son cifras propias de un país
como China o Vietnam
todo esto es sorprendente sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que muchos economistas
llevan años prediciendo un supuesto
colapso económico en Irlanda entre ellos
está el premio Nobel de economía paulman
sin embargo en estos momentos el salario
medio en Irlanda está en los 44.200
dólares anuales y en el año 2015 Irlanda
rompió todos los récords imaginables
cuando crecieron al
25%. sí habéis oído bien 25% de
crecimiento del pib vale este número
tiene trampa pero hablaremos de eso más
adelante La pregunta es por qué Qué hace
que Irlanda sea tan increíblemente
próspera
[Música]
seguramente muchos ya tengáis una
respuesta en la cabeza impuestos bajos
Exacto Irlanda tiene uno de los
impuestos de sociedades más bajos del
mundo esto ha servido para atraer a las
mayores multinacionales del planeta Sin
embargo atentos a esta noticia
la República de Irlanda subirá su
impuesto de sociedades al 15%. y la
pregunta es ahora que van a subir el
impuesto de sociedades se acabó la
gallina de los huevos de oro O tal vez
Irlanda es mucho más que simplemente un
país con impuestos bajos Por qué Irlanda
es tan rico y porque siguen creciendo
como si fueran un país emergente hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
tu Boston
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
Especialmente los que veáis este vídeo
desde los Estados Unidos lo primero que
os viene a la cabeza cuando pensáis en
Irlanda es el desfile de San Patricio en
Boston este desfile que ya se ha hecho
famoso por el tradicional concierto de
Los murphys Y sí habéis oído bien he
dicho Boston Massachusetts en Estados
Unidos y no he hablado de dublín por qué
lo cierto Es que hay más descendientes
de irlandeses viviendo en Estados Unidos
que en la propia Irlanda atentos a esta
gráfica
aquí podéis ver como Irlanda ha estado
perdiendo población desde el siglo XIX
Es decir desde antes incluso de
independizarse de Reino Unido y esto
tiene una explicación pobreza durante
siglos la isla de Irlanda era parte del
Reino Unido pero eran pobres de
solemnidad los irlandeses eran
claramente ciudadanos de segunda y no
creáis que hablamos de la típica pobreza
de dentro del primer mundo no hablamos
de auténtica miseria para que os hagáis
una idea solo en los años 40 del siglo
XIX más de un millón de irlandeses
murieron de hambre sin embargo en el año
1937 y tras una cruenta guerra civil la
República de Irlanda redactó su
Constitución sin embargo la pobreza y el
hambre persistieron Por qué la respuesta
está en la política
[Música]
tras independizarse Irlanda apostó por
un modelo económico basado en la
autosuficiencia pensadlo bien Estados
Unidos todavía estaba recuperándose del
crack del 29 el Libre Mercado no estaba
precisamente de moda Así que Irlanda
quería conseguir la independencia
económica y no querían importar nada del
exterior conclusión pues ya os lo podéis
imaginar el proteccionismo rara vez
funciona pero es que si hay un país
donde es aún más difícil que funcione
ese era precisamente Irlanda pensar que
hablamos de una isla con menos de 4
millones de habitantes que a duras penas
estaba industrializada como os podéis
imaginar es difícil que una economía Tan
pequeña pueda llegar a ser
autosuficiente así que ante la falta de
importaciones Irlanda siguió liderando
la exportación de una cosa irlandeses
eso explica que algunas ciudades
americanas como Boston tengan una
conexión tan fuerte con Irlanda
sin embargo las cosas empezaron a
cambiar en el año 1959 con este señor
que veis en pantalla son Thomas o Kelly
esta señora era el Primer Ministro de
Irlanda y es el padre del primer intento
de liberalizar la economía irlandesa y
diréis por qué digo intento de Pues
porque el Bueno veo que él hizo lo
aplicó algunas partes de la receta en el
año 1959 creó una zona de libre comercio
al lado del aeropuerto de Shannon Así es
como llegaron las primeras empresas
extranjeras durante las décadas
posteriores Irlanda redujo los impuestos
a empresas para traer aún más
corporaciones por ejemplo Apple se
estableció en Irlanda en el año 1980 sin
embargo nada de esto sirvió para que los
irlandeses vivieran mejor Más bien todo
lo contrario por un lado las empresas
extranjeras se limitaban a establecer
sus sedes Fiscales nada más es decir que
las primeras oficinas de Apple o de
Hewlett packard tenían solo unos pocos
contables en plantilla pero no solo eso
por aquellos años Irlanda Apenas tenía
industria sus empresas estaban ancladas
en el siglo XIX Así que al permitir las
de productos extranjeros reventaban el
mercado conclusión en el año 1987 cuando
nací yo Irlanda tenía un paro del 17%,
Los sueldos serán una tercera parte de
su equivalente en Reino Unido e Irlanda
volvía a liderar una exportación
irlandeses dicho de otra forma por mucho
que Irlanda bajara su impuesto de
sociedades el país seguía siendo pobre y
la pregunta es Entonces cómo ha llegado
Irlanda a ser el tigre Celta que
conocemos hoy en día pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
el rugido del tigre Celta
la pregunta la gran pregunta de la
Irlanda de los años 80 era que hace
falta para que las multinacionales
contraten irlandeses vale Ok os estamos
poniendo la alfombra roja para que
montéis oficinas en nuestro país pero
queremos oficinas de verdad no solo una
sede fiscal Pues bien esa es la pregunta
que se hizo el señor Charles hackney que
era el Primer Ministro de Irlanda en
1987 este buen señor y su equipo se
dieron cuenta de una cosa sí es cierto
Irlanda tenía impuestos bajos para
empresas pero todo lo demás era un
auténtico caos los trabajadores tenían
que pagar hasta un 60% de impuesto de la
renta y la legislación laboral era tan
estricta que contratar y despedirse
convertía en un auténtico vía crucis
burocrático conclusión hakny hizo la
auténtica liberalización que Irlanda
necesitaba y los resultados no se
hicieron esperar la planta de HP en
leslieve dará 2000 trabajos para el año
2000 de repente los medios irlandeses
empezaron a publicar noticias como esta
casi todos los meses para es una idea en
poco más de una década los irlandeses
pasaron de cobrar dos terceras partes de
lo que cobraban sus vecinas ingleses y
les superaron
[Música]
eran los años del tigre Celta el país
estaba onfire pero esperad un momento
porque no solo hablamos de
multinacionales por estos años surgieron
un montón de gigantes irlandeses os
suena primark o suena ryanair Pues todo
esto son empresas que nacieron o que
empezaron a expandirse por estos años
para que seáis una idea Hablamos de una
época tan próspera Que incluso se llegó
a poner de moda celebrar bodas y
bautizos desde un helicóptero los bancos
daban hipotecas a diestro y siniestro y
los irlandeses se acostumbraron
demasiado pronto a vivir demasiado bien
muy bien dicho de otra forma que Irlanda
era algo así como el sueño húmedo de
cualquier liberal la prueba de que el
Libre Mercado y el capitalismo funciona
de forma casi milagrosa sin embargo la
alegría duró solamente unos años atentos
efecto dominó
podríamos decir que Irlanda es el puente
que une Estados Unidos con Europa y esto
significa que los bancos irlandeses
estaban demasiado expuestos a los bancos
estadounidenses eso explica que la gran
crisis financiera del año 2008 golpeara
especialmente Irlanda atentos a esta
gráfica
[Música]
aquí podéis ver como Irlanda sufrió una
recesión incluso peor que Estados Unidos
y ya os podéis imaginar la cantidad de
economistas y analistas que por aquellos
años entonaban él te lo dije pero eso no
es todo qué creéis que hizo Irlanda para
evitar el colapso de sus bancos Exacto
pedir un rescato
[Música]
tanto la Unión Europea como el fondo
monetario internacional rescataron
Irlanda con un préstamo de 67.500
millones de euros para que os hagáis una
idea esto es un 40% de todo el pib del
país y diréis cómo quería devolver a
Irlanda todo ese dinero Exacto con
medidas de austeridad dicho de otra
forma Irlanda subió algunos impuestos
indirectos y recortó el gasto público en
todos los frentes bajaron Los sueldos a
los funcionarios en un 14%. cerraron
hasta 41 agencias del gobierno y como os
podéis imaginar todo esto desató Las
mayores protestas de la Irlanda moderna
y ahí es cuando los economistas como
Paul krugman volvieron a entonar el te
lo dije
atentos
Irlanda está ahora en su tercer año de
austeridad y la confianza sigue cayendo
deberíais preguntaros Qué hace falta
para que la gente seria se dé cuenta de
que castigará la población por los
pecados de sus banqueros es peor con
crimen es un error Paul krugman en The
New York Times quedaos con esta cita es
de un artículo escrito en el año 2010
Pues bien dos años más tarde el tiempo
decidió contradecir al bueno de Paul
croman atentos
[Música]
como podéis ver Irlanda no solo se ha
recuperado de la crisis es que ahora
mismo es sustancialmente más rico que el
propio Estados Unidos y sí fijaos bien
en El Salto que da entre 2014 y 2016 Esa
es la fecha en la que Irlanda batió
todos los récords y llegó a crecer hasta
un 25% de su pib La pregunta es cómo lo
hicieron hay algo de trampa ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
cuando el pib no es suficiente
imaginaos la cara del bueno de Paul
krustman predijo el colapso económico de
Irlanda una austericidio que nunca llegó
en pocos años Irlanda dejó de lado la
crisis de deuda y volvió a crecer como
si no hubiera mañana no solo a crecer es
que incluso llegó a batir todos los
récords de la historia económica una
tasa del crecimiento del
25%. boom Sorry not Sorry china Así que
qué creéis que hizo el bueno de Paul
crosman puedes ponerse a investigar la
auténtica razón de ese crecimiento tan
espectacular atentos la economía de
leprechaun Irlanda reporta un 26% de
crecimiento esto no tiene sentido porque
está esto en el pib Paul krugman y lo
cierto Es que en este caso Cruz mantenía
toda la razón del mundo esa subida del
más del 25% del pib se debe a que las
grandes multinacionales principalmente
Apple movieron sus beneficios e Irlanda
para beneficiarse de esos impuestos tan
bajos para que os hagáis una idea
solamente Apple llegó a mover más de 147
mil millones de euros a Irlanda entre
2004 2014 se trata de una simple
operación financiera pero 147 mil
millones de euros es una auténtica
salvajada de dinero sobre todo para un
país pequeño como Irlanda con un pib que
ahora en 2022 está en los 418.000
millones de euros dicho de otra forma la
estadística no refleja la realidad todo
ese dinero de Apple no ha llegado de
verdad a la economía irlandesa en
realidad es solo un número en un balance
y lo cierto Es que Apple no son los
únicos
según el fmi el 60% de la inversión
extranjera en Irlanda son simples
números a todo esto croodman lo llamó
leprecon economics los leprecom son unos
duendes de la mitología irlandesa dicho
de otra forma que la econometría clásica
Simplemente no funciona en Irlanda las
distorsiones estadísticas creadas por el
impacto de los activos globales y las
actividades de las multinacionales en
las cuentas nacionales irlandesas se han
vuelto tan grandes que el pib de
Irlandés ahora una broma patriconohan es
gobernador del Banco Central de Irlanda
de hecho a día de hoy Irlanda utiliza
unas magnitudes distintas que el resto
de países para medir su economía y
diréis cuáles son esas magnitudes Cómo
se mide el pib pues este tipo de
preguntas no son propias de
visualpolitik pero sí tienen cabida en
visual económico por si no lo sabéis
tenemos un canal hermano donde hablamos
en profundidad de nuestra otra gran
pasión la economía si os interesa en
este tipo de cuestiones os esperamos por
ahí pero volvamos ahora con nuestra
historia de hoy porque distorsiones
estadísticas aparte el fenómeno de las
leprecó sirvió para poner en el centro
del debate todos esos esquemas Fiscales
de Irlanda
montones de multinacionales han estado
aprovechando los impuestos bajos de
Irlanda para crear toda clase de
esquemas Fiscales con los que pagar muy
pocos impuestos de hecho para el año
2017 tanto la Unión Europea como Estados
Unidos ya han sacado varias medidas para
evitar la competencia fiscal de Irlanda
pero no solo eso el propio gobierno de
Irlanda ya se ha comprometido a subir
los impuestos atentos la República de
Irlanda subirá su impuesto de sociedades
a 15%. y la pregunta es hasta qué punto
Paul brookman tiene razón es decir si la
riqueza de Irlanda se debe simplemente a
trampas contables y tributación baja
estamos ante el fin del Milagro Irlandés
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
Island
[Música]
vamos a decirlo claro el éxito de
Irlanda no consiste en atraer a grandes
empresas con impuestos bajos si la
prosperidad fuera tan simple como bajar
impuestos andorra sería un país de
millonarios y liberiando sería tan pobre
el auténtico éxito de Irlanda consiste
en haber logrado que esas empresas se
establezcan de verdad en el país y
contratan gente no solo eso Irlanda ha
conseguido que surjan en el propio país
empresas propias que ya son gigantes por
ejemplo os suena ryanair se trata del
gigante de los vuelos low cost seguro
que Si vivís en Europa algún día habréis
volado con esta empresa se trata de una
de las empresas más disruptivas de la
historia pero lo cierto Es que ryanair
solo es la punta del iceberg de una
industria muchísimo más grande puede que
os sorprenda pero Irlanda es la potencia
mundial en aerolíneas tal cual como lo
oís quedaos con estos nombres aircap ji
y capital aviation Services o avolon
seguramente nunca hayáis oído hablar de
estas empresas verdad Pues bien son los
Titanes del alquiler de aviones
comerciales
veréis la mayor parte de las aerolíneas
comerciales del mundo no tienen sus
propios aviones los alquilan Pues bien
el 22% de los aviones comerciales que
vuelan en el mundo vienen de empresas Y
irlandesas cómo os quedáis Hablamos de
una industria que he llegado a dar más
de 4.000 puestos de trabajo y que me
decís del Software cierto este es el
sector Donde están todas esas grandes
multinacionales desde Google hasta
Facebook todas Ellas tienen su sede
fiscal en Irlanda pero no solo hablamos
de sedes Fiscales solo el sector del
Software da trabajo a 24.000 personas
todo esto está muy bien si tenemos en
cuenta que la población de Irlanda no
llega a los 5 millones de habitantes en
otras palabras que la economía de
Irlanda no solo está hiper diversificada
Además está llena de líderes mundiales y
todo esto explica que ni siquiera el
coronavirus haya hecho Mella en el país
dicho de otra forma No parece que
Irlanda este al borde de ninguna crisis
importante al menos no el tipo de crisis
que se imaginaría el bono de Paul
krustman significa esto que los irla no
tienen ningún problema no exactamente
pero hablamos de otro tipo de problemas
atentos la crisis de la vivienda decidir
al futuro político de Irlanda Exacto
Esta es la cara B del éxito económico
Irlanda ya no exporta mano de obra todo
lo contrario ciudades como dublín o cork
que están recibiendo gente de todas
partes y apenas hay casas para hospedar
a tantas personas no hablamos de un
problema menor y además se trata de algo
que afecta a muchos otros países pero
Irlanda tiene un problema especialmente
acuciante en este sentido la pregunta
ahora es Cómo se puede solucionar y lo
que es más importante qué lecciones se
pueden sacar del modelo Irlandés para
otros países como creéis que le afectará
a Irlanda la crisis provocada por la
Guerra de Ucrania podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y recordad
visitar nuestro canal visual economic
donde hablamos en profundidad de todos
estos temas tan fascinantes que bueno
pues en nuestra otra gran pasión la
economía y por supuesto No olvidéis que
aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]